[Musique]
jeanne moreau qui vient d'obtenir
l'oscar de la meilleure actrice
française a accepté de se prêter au jeu
et de la vérité la vedette de la bonne
soupe de la chatte sur un toit brûlant
des amants et qui sera demain madame de
merteuil dans les liaisons dangereuses à
dire prête généralement à la scène et à
l'écran des rôles qui sont à la limite
de l'audace audace sentimentale audace
de caractère audace des situations on
imagine mal en effet comment on pourrait
être plus audacieux sans passer la
mesure pirandello a écrit l'histoire
d'une vedette qui aime un homme lequel
ne peut accepter que cette femme se
donne en pâture au public
nous avons voulu savoir si cette
situation était pas sans dommages pour
la vie privée de jeanne moreau
permettez-moi jeanne moreau de vous
tendre ce miroir qui sera si vous voulez
bien le symbole de ce jeu de la vérité
est d'abord je voudrais vous demander si
vous aimez votre visage votre silhouette
non vous n'avez jamais mais non je ne
peux pas dire que je l'aimé je me suis
habitué mais je ne peux pas dire que
j'ai un goût particulier pour mon visage
mince silhouette
etes-vous ce que l'on appelle et vous
selon vous ce qu'on appelle sexy je ne
peux pas dire que je pense que je le
sois mais j'étais obligé d'accepter ce
jugement parce que on me l'a fait
comprendre et sexy peut-être n'est pas
exactement le mot je crois que je plais
enfin le fait d'avoir du succès c'est ça
veut dire que je plais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas gêné par le fait que la
plupart de vos attitudes physiques
devant flex de veau ou même 20 de vos
tic les plus légers sont connus par des
millions de personnes et surtout par
ceux de votre entourage
oui bien sûr c'est un génome cela est
gênant parce que vous m'en parlez je
dois vous avouer très sincèrement que je
n'y ai pas pensé de cette façon là et
puis surtout j'ai l'impression que étant
une comédienne
lorsque j interprète un personnage
semoun qui me sont particulières ou ses
expressions qui me sont particulières je
les attributs un personnage alors j'ai
l'impression que dans ma vie courante
ces expressions sont différentes je me
trompe peut-être sûrement bien sûr est
ce que le vizir des hommes qui sont vos
admirateurs à l'écran vous jeunes dans
la vie non non je n'ai jamais été
soumise à certaines situations et
respectueuse et même à la suite de la
projection des amants je n'ai pas reçu
de lettre ayant un temps particulier que
j'aurais pu trouver injurieux au
contraire excusez moi d'insister mais
lorsque vous me mets à l'écran où la
passion par exemple vous avez une
certaine façon de prendre visage d'un
homme de l'étreindre de l'embrasser men
qui vous est très particulier afin que
l'on retrouve dans tous vos films
est ce que dans la vie c'est même
situation
lorsque vous les ressentais intensément
ne sont pas diminué d'une partie de leur
vérité de leur qualité par le fait que à
l'écran et à la scène vous avez tenu les
mêmes rôles mais c'est pas à moi qu'il
faudrait poser cette question parce que
moi j'ai l'impression d'être différente
dans ma vie privée
et cette situation passionnel qui est
provoquée sur un plateau de cinéma ou un
plateau de théâtre pour moi est
extrêmement douloureuses et difficiles
et j'ai pas l'impression
d'être spontané fait tout ça est une
question d'imagination et de mémoire
pour moi ce n'est pas une question de
vérité face et ça jouer la comédie je
crois vous n'avez jamais l'impression de
jouer dans la vie
la comédie non j'aurais peut-être cette
impression là si quelqu'un un jour me
disais mais j'ai déjà vu cette
expression quelque part est ce qu'il ne
vous est jamais arrivé dans la ville de
vous arrêter brusquement au moment où
vous alliez prononcer un mot un mot un
être aimé par exemple parce que c'était
justement le mot d'un rôle au non ça
n'est pas arrivé je trouve que cela peut
arriver aussi bien à des gens qui ne
joue pas la comédie parce que les mots
sont toujours les mêmes les êtres change
quelques fois et les situations sont les
mêmes
enfin je suis comédienne mais je crois
qu'il ya des femmes à qui il est arrivé
de dire les mêmes phrases à des hommes
différents
est ce que vous pourriez aimer une
vedette et croire à son amour
ça c'est je pense pas que je pourrais
aimer à l'acteur non pourquoi je ne sais
pas je trouve que c'est un métier déjà
difficile à accepter pour une femme mais
pour un homme c'est une situation encore
plus particulière alors il faut les
qualités de féminité d'ambiguïté qui ne
sont pas des qualités particulièrement
masculine est un homme qui est comme ça
n'est pas un homme véritable tout une
condamnation je ne sais pas est ce que
vous pourriez être autre chose qu
actrice
oui quoi être une femme simplement parce
que vous avez déjà songé à renoncer à
votre carrière
est ce que vous êtes fixé une date oui
je me suis fixé de date je peux vous le
dire quand j'ai débuté quand j'ai
commencé à travailler
je me suis donné dix ans pour arriver à
être quelque chose ou quelqu'un qui me
ressemble et ses 10 ans sont écoulés
vous avez réussi
oui et puis maintenant je me donne
encore dix ans est-ce qu'on peut pendant
dix ans jouer le jeu vous avez joué dans
la vie à la scène et à l'écran sans être
autre chose que soi même sans être
brusquement un double et avoir des
comptes à rendre à ce double
oui
peut-être oui est ce que vous êtes sûr
maintenant que si vous choisissiez de
renoncer vous pourriez réellement à
cette seconde moi personnellement j'en
doute mais j'ai l'impression brusquement
l'actrice comment avec la femme sans
tête obligé de dire oui mais la
situation ici est particulière parce que
malgré tout cette interview et n'a pas
été préparée il est improvisé mais je
suis quand même dans des éléments qui
ressemble à ce que je connais c'est à
dire les projecteurs les caméras les
questions précises et ces questions que
vous posez vous les posez à jeanne
moreau et alors je suis tiraillé je suis
pas dans une situation véritable
douzaine comédie
jusqu'à un certain point oui et c'est un
homme que vous aimiez qui voulait poser
brusquement ce serait évidemment très
différent ce serait différent mais le
problème c'est quand même le même parce
que ces projecteurs vous les aimez ces
caméras vous vous vivez d'elle et où
vivait avec elle
vous auriez à résoudre quand la même
équation je vous assure que je pourrais
m'en passer vraiment vous le croyez ah
oui et bien écoutez je crois que on peut
se séparer
cette certitude merci
[Musique]